[Music]
said something recently you said that
you wanted to have sex with Prince
Charles yes you just came out and said
that yes I have a lot of questions first
of all did this hurt Ozzy's feelings at
all that you said that no because he can
miller while I'm with because I want to
Title I they call it a Dame and they
make you a game wait did you say that if
you sleep with Prince Charles you get a
title I don't think that's true no you
just have to
[Applause]
what the hell was that
is it true
[Laughter]
she said that you would if you wanted to
do this what are the repercussions I
mean did you ever hear from the Royals
did you ever hear back as you you have
socialized with these people yes sat
down you've broken bread with Prince
Charles with Camilla yes
what about did they respond to this when
you said it well I didn't exactly like
go right for it I kind of like skirted
around the perimeter okay right you know
oh you proposed a couple swabs yeah when
you were with Prince Prince Charles have
you ever flirted with him directly have
you ever made yes I do this on his leg
while we're talking anything dinner
just show me excited
yeah you did that okay now I get I can't
I couldn't tell from this alley so we do
this and we Chitty chatty and we respond
so you rub his leg okay
just the low knee area of the leg ish if
it drifted a little north my bed down to
pick up my napkin and as I came up I
accidentally knocked him knocked him in
the crotch in the crotch this is turning
into a legal benefit for the hunt for
the Royal jewels
[Laughter]